[Music]
hey what you doing oh I'm just nailing
my most valuable possession to the wall
jasbeer no not the dog my college
diploma oh right
yep this little piece of paper cost me
three hundred and twenty dollars per
square inch ah it's almost as much as a
Manhattan apartment it does kind of make
you wonder I mean would I have been
happier if I chosen another major or
gone to trade school instead at least
you'd know that you can't hammer a screw
into a wall huh I just thought it was a
fancy nail
[Music]
it's not exactly a newsflash that
college is expensive graduates our age
have an average of 37 thousand one
hundred seventy two dollars in student
loan debt and they have to start
thinking about their own kids college if
Philip and I had a baby this year at
around four percent inflation per year
in-state tuition would run us about one
hundred and sixty two thousand dollars
now there isn't one explanation why
tuitions are inflating like our
microwaved peep but there are some
strong theories supply and demand over
the last 40 years having an
undergraduate degree went from being
considered an option to a necessity and
the more people want something the more
the people selling it can charge another
theory puts the blame on student loans
wait how does that make sense well
they're scary easy to get colleges have
no incentive to control costs because
they know the federal government and
other loan agencies will keep fronting
the money and finally an administration
of costs have ballooned as much as 60
percent in the last 25 years a lot of
that gets blamed on perks that colleges
are adding to attract customers I mean
students Davidson College offers free
laundry service Michigan Tech has an
on-campus ski resort of course education
is about more than just dollars and
cents but there's no denying college is
a financial investment you're paying all
this money now in the hopes that you'll
be able to make it back later
so will you for most people yes the
question is how long will it take and
that depends on your degree so which
majors pay for themselves the fastest
let's run the numbers
we'll start with the median income for
somebody with only a high school diploma
compare that with a college graduate
with say a communications degree that's
an extra $15,000 per year now that but
how much did it cost the average cost of
tuition room and board at an in-state
university is 80 thousand three hundred
and sixty dollars so our communications
major will break even on their
investment in about five point three
years a psychology major will take 11
years to break even an arts major will
take 8 point 8 business the most popular
major will break even in 3.2 and the
most lucrative undergraduate major of
all engineering will pay for itself in
just two years okay but what about
graduate school while it's true that
some postgraduate degrees can push your
income into the next tax bracket these
percentages don't tell the whole story
take law school the average law student
graduates with somewhere between 85
thousand and a hundred and twenty-five
thousand dollars in extra debt on top of
their undergraduate loans while the top
students at the most prestigious
universities can pull down big bucks
right away they're in the minority
almost half of LA grads earn a median
starting salary only $65,000 a year
that's just a fifteen thousand dollar
pay bump for an extra hundred thousand
dollars of debt
okay how about med school that's gotta
pay off big-time right well the median
salary for a general practitioner is a
hundred seventy-five thousand a year but
the average cost of medical school at a
public university is around two hundred
thousand when you factor in your
undergraduate loans and the interest
that debt is racking up while you're in
residency it's very common for doctors
to end up paying almost half a million
dollars over 25 years for those two
letters behind their name if all of this
is sounding scary or discouraging just
remember that statistically it does pay
to go to college in the long run
whatever your major and there are things
that you can do early on that will ease
the debt burden down the road shop
around most universities can supply you
with the information about how much
their alumni make in the work force
they might even connect you with
graduates of your same major who can
answer your specific questions and when
comparing prices make sure you factor in
the cost of living some cities are so
expensive to live in it can double the
amount you'll have to borrow consider
Community College there's a stigma that
it's only for people who can't get into
real college but it's actually a really
smart decision you can slash your
undergraduate debt in half and not get
locked into a lifelong financial
commitment at the wise old age of 18
that's what Philip did and today we have
the exact same diploma from the same
University but mine cost more than twice
as much and lastly look into alternative
financing there are companies and
colleges that are trying out a
newfangled approach called income share
agreements in which the student agrees
to pay a fixed percentage of their
salary for a fixed period of time unlike
a loan which relentlessly accrues
interest through good times and bad
ISAs don't punish the borrower for
making less money than they hoped
they're basically betting on you to do
well and sharing some of the risk if you
don't now most people don't choose their
major for purely economic reasons people
want to do what they love and what
they're good at and no PowerPoint
presentation is gonna change their minds
and there are benefits to college that
you can't quantify like broadening your
horizons or meeting your future husband
being money smart doesn't mean basing
your life around money
it just means taking simple precautions
early on so you can chase your dreams
without weights around your ankles and
that's our two cents
you